zurück aus der sommerpause und direkt
mitten im spannendsten wahlkampf aller
zeiten eine bundestagswahl bei der man
vorher nicht weiß wer gewinnt dass so
was erlaubt ist oder man reibt sich
wirklich nur noch die augen meine damen
und herren nach all den schneidigen
rojahn ist endlich der gute alte
lagerwahlkampf zurück und die union
diese woche in einer forsa umfrage nur
noch bei 19 prozent
mit einem kanzlerkandidaten der ja man
muss es so sagen einen spektakulären
anti lauf hat es ist der nackte wahnsinn
freunde armin laschet wird inzwischen
sogar in kindernachrichten verhöhnt
wirklich mir geht das zu weit selbst die
fragen bei logo klingen irgendwie
hämisch was bedeutet das wort los
irgendwie verloren ja nicht gewonnen
werden so schwierig ist hoffnungslos
deprimierend kein bock mehr es stimmt
alles ja wenn sie bei google lost
eingeben kommt ein foto von armin
laschet manchmal wird es dann auch echt
unfair inzwischen und albern weil er es
den leuten scheinbar gar nicht mehr
recht machen kann
dann heißt es kuck mal wer trägt feine
slipper im hochwassergebiet la die da
oder kurz danach auch nie jetzt richter
gummistiefel was glaubt ihr denn da ist
ja leck mich fett jetzt frisst an eis
obwohl die polkappen schmelzen
gab es in der geschichte deutschland
überhaupt schon mal ein politiker der so
einstecken musste völlig egal wasser
macht
klar
wer war das ja ich sage aber auch nicht
zu früh abschreiben den herrn laschet
vorsicht laschet war in seiner karriere
ständig am boden zieht sich durch seine
biografie und hat dann doch immer
irgendwie gewonnen man könnte sagen
laschet ist der plot sämtlicher rocky
filme ganz klar am manches wirkt jetzt
schon sehr verzweifelt was da passiert
man zb die cdu idee von laschet
abzulenken mit unzähligen teams die sich
irgendwie um ihn herum stellen sollen
wie zum beispiel die meisten von denen
kennen sich nicht mehr untereinander im
sogenannten zukunft system gibt es
tatsächlich nur einen echten star
friedrich merz
cdu die super jetzt der 80er 90er und
das beste von heute wenn das nicht hilft
die union war sich todsicher immer total
sicher ohne uns kann er keine regierung
gebildet werden leute wozu überhaupt
wahlkämpfen oder sich inhalte überlegen
und jetzt plötzlich aus dem nichts diese
dramatik
herbst 20 21 ein politisches beben
erschütterte berlin die verängstigte
bevölkerung hält den atem an angesichts
dieser schock nachricht
armin laschet verschanzt sich mit seinem
letzten aufgebot dem zukunftsteam mit
dabei das gesicht der zukunft friedrich
merz und seit neuestem auch konrad
adenauer sehen sie bilbo beutlin als
armin laschet diese raufasertapete als
olaf scholz und so wirklich allerletzten
mal sehr an die partie als angela merkel
will armin calypso
junge junge braucht der mann
nehmerqualitäten
71 prozent der deutschen halten laschet
für nicht kanzler fähig das ist wirklich
ein neuer rekord auf der nach unten
offenen scharping skala diese woche hat
er gesagt er will bis zur wahl nicht
mehr über umfragen reden natürlich auch
eine lösung ich sage mal weg ist sein
eigener verein zu ihm halten würde hier
so genannter cdu wahlkampf auf die
plakate kommt armin laschet auch hier
heute nicht wahlkampf stand von berliner
cdu kandidaten vergangene woche eine
partei die ihren eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten weitgehend versteckt
wir haben selbstverständlich das
werbematerial des bundesverbandes oft
dabei
und das machen wir sozusagen natürlich
auch natürlich haben wir auch dabei die
ganzen laschet flyer da vorne liegen sie
doch in den mülleimer ja solche
parteifreunde wünscht man echt kein so
ferne und wenn heuchelei endlich
olympisch wird dann holt er hier
garantiert immer gold ich finde es ist
eigentlich aus ziemlich unfair wie armin
laschet von vielen in den medien oder in
sozialen medien behandelt wird es ist
ich sage das ausdrücklich unerhört wie
ein verdienter man die armin laschet
unter anderem von mir gemobbt wird der
typ kennt echt gar keine skrupel mehr er
übrigens söder csu steht in bayern
aktuell bei 28 prozent aber das nur am
rande die lage der union ist so
verzweifelt
angela merkel hat diese woche persönlich
im bundestag dazu aufgerufen armin
laschet zu wählen als sozialdemokrat in
und mal ganz ehrlich diese cdu krise
liegt ja vielleicht nicht nur daran dass
der armin im falschen moment mein eis
geschleckt hat einfach mal aus spaß drei
unlustige fakten zum thema was
hinterlässt denn frau merkel
stichwort pflegenotstand allein in
krankenhäusern fehlen jetzt gerade 100
1000 vollzeitstellen oder
investitionsstau der liegt bei rund 150
milliarden nur die maroden schulen
bräuchten 44 und ganz aktuelle meldungen
aus dieser woche laut einer neuen studie
ist deutschland in sachen digitale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit
vorletzter in europa nur noch vor
albanien
vor albanien bei dem thema digitale
wettbewerbsfähigkeit haben wir uns in
den letzten drei jahren zurück
entwickelt sagt die studie trotz des
ganzen digitalisierungs gelagert ja so
wird also ausgerechnet olaf scholz als
kommender deutscher kanzler gehandelt
wie genau war das möglich oder was
stimmt nicht mit uns klar gute umfragen
führen zu guten umfragen denn der mensch
will immer zu den siegern gehören
deswegen werden doofe kinder ja auch
bayern fans und was dem urlaub auch
enorm hilft dieser ganze comic skandal
ist vielen einfach zu komplex oder es
ist noch simpler und in einer welt des
rasanten wandels wirkt so ein scholz
einfach ja beruhigend ist ja nur alter
trick wer wenig macht macht wenig falsch
viele wissen das gar nicht wenn sie
online den wahl o maten aufrufen und
dann völlig emotions und regungslos 15
minuten vor ihrem rechner sitzen und
absolut nichts machen dann empfiehlt der
wahlomat eigentlich immer spd ja machst
du nix oder scholz ein wie wir gelernt
haben finanzminister der offenbar seine
eigene zollbehörde nicht im griff hat
vielleicht bald kanzler der ampel oder
doch kanzler von erz wo geht das
schreckgespenst rot rot grün der letzte
innerhalb den die arme union noch hat
wir müssen jetzt noch mehr aufzeigen was
diesem land droht das ein linksbündnis
ein anderes deutschland wäre da würde
sich deutschland zum negativen
entwickeln wenn wir rot-rot-grün bekämen
jetzt gilt es in diesen entscheidenden
stunden einen linksrutsch zu verhindern
wurde auch ein jahrzehnt des
wirtschaftlichen niedergangs mit
rot-rot-grün gott schütze uns vor eis
und schnee den grünen den linken und der
spd die befreiende lieber weiter masken
schmidt beide stimmen cdu
ob das noch so zieht die panik von rot
rot grünen regierung
guck dir berlin an dessen schlechtes
beispiel ja immer wieder holen sie ihre
gammeligen roten socken raus hier
original plakat von 1953 gab es da schon
rote hand greift nach einem baby um es
in einen linksgrünen veganen gulag zu
stecken oder so höchste zeit für eine
sondersendung
breaking news alarmstufe rot rot grün
hilfe die kommunisten kommen
[Musik]
ja liebe zuschauer noch weiß ja keiner
ob er wirklich kommt aber allein die
möglichkeit verbreitet schockwellen da
ist es schon eine neutrale satire
sendung bezahlt von ihren gebühren das
mindeste mal auszuloten was uns droht
wir schalten live an die schweizer
grenze nach weil am rhein zu ulrich von
heesen ulrich was passierte oliver hier
spielen sich dramatische szenen ab ein
nicht enden wollender strom von
deutschen leistungsträgern versucht noch
rechtzeitig in die schweiz zu liegen ich
sehe nackte angst in den gesichtern
dieser einfachen investmentbanker und
schönheitschirurg kein wunder hier
wahlprogramm der linken höhere
erbschaftssteuer vermögensabgabe
spitzensteuersatz 53 prozent so besteht
hier
die linken wollen die schaumweinsteuer
abschaffen japan ja würde billiger
jetzt kommen sie alle zurück das ging ja
zum glück komplett ohne klischees ab und
ich höre gerade meine damen und herren
es gibt neuigkeiten aus afghanistan aus
kabul wir schalten zu birte schneider
würde die taliban geben eine
pressekonferenz das ist richtig oliver
die taliban hatten deutschland ja gerade
erst aufgefordert diplomatische
beziehungen aufzunehmen
und ich höre gerade das ziehen sie jetzt
zurück der taliban-sprecher sagt rot rot
grün sei kein seriöser partner und leute
wie sahra wagenknecht während ihm noch
einfach so radikal wie schade muss man
aber akzeptieren ich gebe direkt weiter
an ulrich von heesen live an der a3 bei
leverkusen
würde jetzt ist es passiert vielen dank
auch bündnis 90 die doofen
zwölf kilometer lastenfahrrad stau
richtung oberhausen seit die grünen 1000
euro pro lastenrad versprechen kaufen
sich alle deutschen so eine idiotin ri
cha
das ist das grüne paradies auf das wir
uns alle freuen sollen und es betrifft
ja nicht nur den verkehr
wenn die grünen am ruder sind dann geht
die gender polizei demnächst von tür zu
tun und jeder zizmann der zu hause ist
muss seine pläne ist abgeben fakt habe
ich im internet gelesen ich will meinen
penis aber nicht abgeben der ist auch
gut ja gut zu wissen wird schneider an
der frankfurter börse wie ist denn da
auf dem parkett die stimmung ich habe
was glauben sie denn das einzige was
hier noch läuft sind cannabis aktien
wegen der gerüchte über den pfiff zwang
für alle ab 12 aber sonst bundesweiter
mieten deckel kindergrundsicherung 3 10
euro mindestlohn pures börsen gift ich
sage nur keine deutschen rüstungsexporte
mehr in krisengebiete
ein wahnsinn hier
der großaktionär von heckler & koch
versucht sich seit stunden zu erschießen
aber wieder mit dem g36 scheiß teil
wird sorry entschuldigung ich muss sie
leider unterbrechen aber der kollege
ulrich von heesen meldet sich nochmal
mit neuigkeiten von der a3 blicke ich
wollte noch mal klarstellen die grünen
kriegen meinen penis auf keinen fall
from may co der leyens ja ist
klargeworden danke so dann schalten wir
zum guten schluss noch mal zur zdf
zentrale am mainzer lerchenberg wird was
ändert sich denn demnächst bei uns ja
was wohl das zdf wird natürlich auch
komplett auf links gedreht hier und so
kommen das programmschema die gute
nachricht bei baris für rares bleibt
fast alles gleich nur die händler werden
enteignet jeden abend interviews
chefredakteur peter frey wladimir putin
in der sendung was nun herr putin wir
sind große fans gefolgt von gender
journal mit claus clausen und gundula
kleber aber auch die romantik kommt
nicht zu kurz sonntags heißt es
rosamunde luxemburg der fünfjahresplan
der liebe also da wird tatsächlich eine
menge anders unter rot rot grün nur die
anstalt die canucks fakt so bleiben wie
sie ist gottseidank birte schneider und
ulrich von heesen vielen dank
breaking news alarmstufe rot rot grün
hilfe die kommunisten kommen
so
aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and cut
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich